Maxim welcome back to St Louis welcome
back to Grand Tour um in the short video
which you made before the tournament
which you sent before the tournament you
specifically mentioned that you're
looking forward to have s Thanksgiving
here um I was wondering what is the most
interesting for you about this holiday
and are you going to discover and some
Black Friday sales
perhaps uh yeah for me it's not really
about the Black Friday sales it's really
about you know I mean I know that
Thanksgiving is a huge tradition in
America and I've never been able to
witness it in person I've seen only SC
from movies and and so on so yeah I'm
looking forward to to look what it's
like uh you know in real life and also I
I hope to have great gifts to celebrate
from my opponents prior to that can you
share actually how many times you've
played in sville cup before actually how
many times you played in St Louis and
which tournament was the most memorable
for you I've played in singfield cup uh
from 2014 onwards so that should be 10
but I think in 2020 because of Co it
hasn't happened so it's my ninth Edition
I won it twice especially the Edition in
2017 that I won ahe of Magnus of all the
top players and uh I did beat Magnus in
that event so that one felt quite
special yeah and um what do you think
think about this one you know rapid and
Blitz and sink will cup what are your
expectations uh I'm definitely hoping to
do well it's the last classical event of
the year with the S Hill cup so I have
my PL has been eratic especially in
classical this year so I'm hoping to
bounce back to to a good waiting so I'm
you know it starts here I think and same
for the grandchester rankings uh I'm
doing decent but I still need two strong
results here to to qualify for next
year's Edition yeah and um you just
coming from Grand SS event yes and I
love men how can you assess your
participation there and let's say um we
know that you lost the opportunity to
play in the candidates because of this
result but in general like what what are
your feelings about this event and how
did you try to recover after it yeah g s
was a tough event for me I I didn't
survive in the physical condition I up
to I was a bit sick from the start I
didn't think it have that much of a
repercussion U but it did in the first
half um and then I recovered quite
nicely but it was not enough so you know
I'm hoping
um yeah to to play better here of
course uh I don't have any doubt that I
can play better so so I will and but
yeah it was a tough event uh lots of
things uh were happening like every day
it was a crazy fight so at least the end
of the tournament as a neutral uh player
like neutral spectator was fun to watch
yeah but now let's say with this event
I'm really sorry to say that but you
lost this chance to get a spot in the
candidates I mean did it change your
goals and approach let's say for the
rest of the let's say year and the next
one did you change your goals um yeah I
mean I wouldn't say that the gr is where
I lost the opportunity to play in the
candidates I think it comes on to my
first half of the Year where my play was
erratic um so after that you know it
doesn't
uh uh it doesn't change my Approach uh
for for next years I'll still be trying
very hard to to compete for the world
championship cycle of course it's a PTI
don't manage to qualify uh for 2024
candidates but then I already set my uh
my eyes on the 2026 exactly I mean of
course and I'm sure your fans also are
looking forward for it thank you so much
Maxim for this interview and all the
best of luck for you in both events yeah
thank
[Music]
you